alors le coup de coeur du si 17 cette
semaine il y en a deux mais je vais
parler principalement du premier film de
nicolas bedos qui s'appelle monsieur
madame adelman qui sont aujourd'hui dans
nos salles c'est un premier film très
réussi
je sais que nicolas bedos est comme ça
pour la sortie de son premier film il a
beaucoup travaillé dessus c'est une
collaboration et doria thiviers avec qui
il a travaillé sur canal+ que ceux qui
regardaient canal+ il ya quelques années
maintenant et c'est savoureuse histoire
d'un couple pendant 45 ans de leur vie
commune de leur rencontre je dirais à
l'heure à leur âge mûr c'est très
savoureux c'est aussi très belle
histoire d'amour ces deux roule c'est
romantique donc c'est vraiment à voir
c'est une pro un premier film je leur
précise et puis un petit coup de coeur
deuxième pour le film de lucas belvaux
on est une seconde lucas belvaux aussi
17 c'est très particulier
venez voir aussi chez nick dans nos
salles qui est une comédie on va dire
dramatiques sur la river et la montée du
front national dans un petit village du
nord de la france
c'est maintenant ou jamais bornes et la
va tout s'est ligué du cul